hello everybody so I think as you know I
just left the Oval Office where
president Trump signed a new executive
orth
order authorizing even more expanded
sanctions against Iran so now with along
with our existing sanctions authorities
we have additional sanctions to go after
the Supreme Leader's office and lock up
literally billions of dollars more of
assets along with that action today we
are also announcing specific actions
targeting those responsible for recent
activities I think as you know
previously we have sanctioned soleimani
for his behavior along with that today I
am going to announce three of his other
senior leaders tank Seri who is
responsible for the Iranian regime's
forces threatening to close the Strait
of Hormuz [ __ ] day who is the commander
of the air force and responsible for
downing the u.s. unmanned air
you
many of these the the executive order
that the President signed was in the
works previously these actions are
people who have either made threats or
specific things and again I don't think
you should interpret this anywhere
otherwise other than we are designating
people who we believe were responsible
for the chain of command whether they
knew it or not what is your response to
your critics who say these sanctions are
more symbolic than substantive and they
won't bring Iran to the negotiating
table because Iran said they're not
coming back to the negotiating table
after the present well I think the
president was very clear if they want to
come back to the negotiating table he's
ready if not they won't for people who
say these are just symbolic that's not
the case at all we've literally locked
up tens and tens of billions of dollars
these sanctions will come along with
additional entities where people are
hiding money so now these sanctions are
highly effective drone what makes you
think that these sanctions have been
effective what signs well there's no
question these sanctions have been very
effective in cutting off funds going to
the our air Jassi and other people and I
can I can only presume I'm not going to
presume why they're doing things but
these are highly highly effective on
locking up the Iranian economy as the
president said we look forward to a time
in releasing sanctions if they're
willing to negotiate
thank you when you talk about sanctions
office Supreme Leader that is as high as
you can go inside of Iran can you give
us the thinking as to why the
administration wanted to bring it up to
that level I think the President and
clear maximum pressure on the sanctions
so that is that is our strategy and it's
not just him it's it's the leaders
office which encompasses a whole range
of activities secretary thank you have
you done the intelligence research to
figure out what assets any of these
individuals that you just named actually
have in the United States or in the
global financial system that is do any
of these people have money or assets
how's that around so the answer is
whenever we do sanctions we do do
intelligence I can't comment on any of
the specific intelligence but again I
would say we follow the money and it's
highly effective it's a military option
or military reprisal is still on the
table I obviously can't comment on that
I'm going to leave that to the president
okay thank you thank you mr. secretary
have you consulted with America's allies
regarding these sanctions and is there
buy-in from America's allies well they
also be imposing sanctions similar to it
I have not consulted on these specific
sanctions the answer is in general I've
had many many conversations with all our
allies I was in Japan ten days ago
meeting with the finance ministers and
discussed our sanctions program I'll be
going to the g20 with the president
again this will continue to be a topic
of discussion you said this is a
response to an events of the recent
events is that about the shooting down
of the drone or the attack on the six
tankers or both again what I said is
some of these were in the works some of
these are in addition all of the above
this is the president came close to
military action now you're coming back
with sanction I guess direct response
some of them I'm not going to identify
which ones are which I've said that some
of this was in the works some of this is
a result of recent activities
how do have these sanctions do have
these sanctions relate to president
Trump's deal of the century what's
happening coming up in Bahrain
I look forward I'm leaving for Bahrain
in about an hour so I look forward to
our discussion in Bahrain we'll be
rolling out the economic plan which will
be great opportunities for the people of
Palestine we have a terrific group there
of finance ministers business leaders
all around the world I think we have
about 350 people going so I look forward
to it talk about the sanctions are
effective in terms of putting pain on
the economy is this reminisce yet or
will there be ovens do you think that
having effect on trance behave well let
me first comment that our issue is not
what the people of Iran so I just want
to be very clear we are not looking at
creating issues for the people of Iran
having said that we are have sanctions
against bad behavior and there's no
question that locking this money up
worked last time
and there's no question locking the
money up works now